hi I'm Ryan Wright and tonight we're
gonna watch the official extended
trailer for Gotham look like the fattest
Batman now wearing glasses cuz
Commissioner Gordon wears glasses
anyway guys yeah we're gonna watch the
official extended trailer for Gotham I'm
excited Batman one of my favorite comics
I've ever read and I have read very few
Batman you're what one of my dreams is
to make it I hope someone doesn't steal
this idea I'm copy writing this verbally
through a youtube video I want to take
not like an independent film but like a
fairly low-budget film for a comic book
movie just take the combat man year 1
story but just focus it on Commissioner
Gordon and then have Bruce Wayne be
featured in it and Batman be featured in
it but the movie never reveals that
Batman and Bruce Wayne are the same so
yeah that would be one of my dream
Batman movies to make I have a lot of
Batman movies in mind actually but yeah
no I like Commissioner Gordon my
favorite portrayal of him is the one in
Batman you're 1 and yeah here has a sexy
[ __ ] who was in the OSI hence
that other cop show thing that's really
cool to me everyone's psyched about this
cast people are responding much better
to this cast than the casting a Man of
Steel - that's for damn sure
oh yeah I heard this idea got really
excited time to watch the trailer now
I'm Superman I love this city
I see it going down you know this is
gonna be a cools down this place is
cursed I won't let it fall apart without
a fight
like music we will not we cannot let
these killers these robbers these
rapists and these ducks with my wife's
hammer there is a war coming a terrible
war please give me a cool Commissioner
or chaos or detector whatever Street
noise
when the partner Jim Gordon you have a
little danger in you know know what you
plan to do is head up Mason shop who
killed people before that was war this
is war
whoa man habits there's really got
[ __ ] up
my name's Bruce Wayne fighting
I'll find the matter to us
a moment to conquer fear doesn't need
conquering fear tells you where the
edges
somebody has to take over the - won't be
me gossip is on that nice room gates got
like enough of that Nolan feel
however dark and scary the world might
be right now there will be light will be
like he's not gonna jump oh very good
nah oh dude it's a full-on origin tale
that looks [ __ ] cool I cannot wait I
haven't been this excited for a new show
in so long like you know you hear new
shows and you're like that sounds
interesting that sounds cool this is a
dream come true for a lot of people I
love it cuz it's got that grounded
reality tape they've tried like
comic-book live-action shows before but
a lot of them don't work too well I like
this cuz it's just a pure origin story
and it looks like it's gonna have some
great drama in it I [ __ ] psyched for
it man
Eduardo Silva he just I just got a
facebook notification from you buddy sup
Matt this is your shout out sorry
could have been better anyway guys if
you're new to the channel subscribe
please uh yeah
subscribe so we could talk more hangout
chillax see this cool Batman shirt I
used to fit into it so [ __ ] well I
really did but then I gained like a [ __ ]
ton of weight I'm where I've been
working out consistently for like the
past three weeks now and I've really use
your guys support on this we really got
me working out let's just hate as
motivate man hate is doing me can't
bring me down [ __ ] all you people out
there would be like you got fat Ryan you
got fat I'd be live [ __ ] you won't prove
you but seriously don't motivate me by
calling me fat that actually hurts my
feelings don't don't do that
Murray she said she'd be over here for a
dear subscriber list Toni Rubert dude
watch 20 of our videos in one day thanks
Tony Tony what are you doing Donna are
you dumb son of a [ __ ] yo yo huh you're
talking to Mike sketch the wretch you're
the [ __ ] every time you take a [ __ ] I
want you to look at it and go that's
what I am Eva Marie you're finally here
hey hey get out of the frame I'm filming
dude's been waiting for a shout-out for
awhile and your shoutout involve Murray
walking through the door hi how lucky
are you
by now Murray she wouldn't want to be in
front of the camera right now she just
woke up some oh my god you're the camera
is your special shadow I don't want to
say this one said it raped that some guy
said he'll rapes a lien I don't want to
shout out that guck it's a we're testing
is it
you know you are said it and there's
someone out there who just has a single
named die and there's just once a agent
chick I knew who had a name that almost
sounded like Diane one time I
accidentally called her Diane and she
flipped the [ __ ] out on me so if you
have a name that sounds like Diane and
your name is not really Diane I am sorry
Diane see I give the best shoutouts